our current generation of human
especially 35 and younger
spins an inordinate amount of time at
home
everybody's just at home all the time
and when you're at home all the time a
there's no real romantic connections
there's no real friendship connections
that happen and the only thing you can
do is scroll and play video games or
watch Netflix that's the only thing you
can do because you're just a home I want
to challenge you to be out of your house
sign up for two classes for 30 days
and do two things that you're going to
be kind of uncomfortable doing it's
going to be a little bit weird and what
you're going to do is if you do one
athletic thing and one artistic thing
and one this thing one that thing
you're gonna find out dude I am not a
jiu jitsu person or you might find out I
love love love love this